have you ever heard of a site called
mega.nz
on the surface the site looks like a
strong competitor to google drive they
offer 20 gigabytes of storage great
encryption and phenomenal download and
upload speeds considering this you would
think that mega is a great alternative
to google drive and icloud but people
using mega aren't saving personal
pictures videos or documents
rather they're uploading and sharing the
latest movies games and software and
instead of the encryption providing
safety for its users it actually makes
it harder for copyright owners to track
down what's being shared any other
founder in this situation would probably
freak out given that they don't want to
be hunted down by the fbi but the
founder of mega kim.com isn't faced by
the fbi
in fact the fbi was hunting down kim
when he launched mega and he's still one
of the most wanted people in the world
so here's the wild story of kim.com and
how mega became the go-to cloud platform
for pirates
taking a look back kim never had a
particularly calm life he was born on
january 21 1974 in west germany and from
a very young age he was interested in
hacking and when i say hacking i don't
mean hacking league of legends or world
of warcraft no him over here was hacking
pbx systems or private branch exchange
systems of us companies when he was just
18 years old he was hacking the likes of
nasa citibank and the pentagon and he
was selling their access codes for 200
if you ask me i think kim was the one
that was really being robbed here
anyway in the beginning kim wanted to be
a cyber security consultant but these
dreams would be crushed very early on
you see it prosecutors weren't exactly
happy that this 18 year old was hacking
into national systems and selling access
to protected data so they kept an
extremely close eye on kim and it didn't
take them long to arrest him in march of
1994 the german police arrested kim for
selling stolen phone numbers and they
threw him in jail for a month right when
he got out they pressed hacking charges
on kim and kim ended up being convicted
for 11 counts of computer fraud and 10
counts of data espionage this itself
could have gotten him locked up for
years but since many of the crimes were
committed when he was a minor the judge
decided to go easy on him the judge
simply gave him a two-year suspended
sentence and wrote off his crimes as
youthful foolishness while kim didn't
have to spend too much time in prison
given his criminal record it was going
to be nearly impossible to get a job but
kim didn't let this slow him down
in fact he used his arrest and
conviction to boost his notoriety and
fame within the hacking space kim became
known as the child prodigy hacker and
kim levered this to make a living he
launched a cyber security company called
data protect it's not clear when exactly
he launched the company but there are
emails suggesting that the company was
operating as early as 1994.
anyway one of their first big contracts
was with the lufthansa airlines the
story goes that kim secured a contract
with lufthansa after showing them how
easily he could hack into the company's
systems but others argue that this is
not actually what went down
first of all they say that it wasn't kim
that did the hacking it was actually one
of his accomplices
and secondly the main reason lufthansa
gave him the contract was not because
they were impressed by the hacking but
because kim had insider contacts we'll
probably never find out what truly went
down but it doesn't really matter for
kim as he started raking in millions
from such contracts with this new influx
of cash kim went on a spending spree
purchasing super cars houses and
helicopters this is when kim's public
persona shifted from being a nerd hacker
to being a rich genius hacker and let's
just say kim loved to play into this
persona
aside from buying expensive toys kim
spent significant amounts of money on
convincing people that he was the hacker
of the people
one example of this was a short
animation film that he produced called
the kimbo special agent the premise of
the film is kim breaking into
microsoft's headquarters to confront
bill gates when kim finally gets the
bill after a crazy sequence of cars
boats and helicopters it's exposed that
bill is actually using an apple macbook
and kim goes ahead and carves out the
word linux on bill's wall while bill
pees his pants it's quite an odd story
but i gotta say it is amusingly
entertaining shortly after kim also
produced another short film called
kimball ghost monaco in this film kim
was just minding his own business and
trying to enjoy his vacation but for
some reason bill gates was spying on him
the entire time when the film launched
it was mostly taken at a satirical jab
at the bill but with the time more and
more people have started to believe that
it's actually true
aside from exposing bill gates kim spent
his time building an internet-based
luxury car called the mega car the
vision was for the car to have a
computer a router a video conferencing
system and a 17 inch display the car was
supposed to launch for 90 000
but the launch date never came around
similar to the car being a false promise
many critics argued that kim's entire
persona was a false promise according to
a new zealand magazine kim was once
spotted taking pictures at an airport
inside parked airplanes and acting as if
they were his own while kim may not have
been as rich as he showed off to be kim
was doing better than ever before
in 2000 he sold 80 percent of data
protect with german conglomerate named
tuv reinland the acquisition price was
not revealed but it was likely in the
tens of millions kim could have called
it quits right here and lived a lavish
life for the rest of his days but kim
was never attracted to the dark side
because of money he liked the dark side
because of the thrill and it didn't take
him very long to push it too far
in january of 2001 when the dotcom crash
was starting to take full effect a
company called let's buy it.com was
nearing bankruptcy instead of letting
the company die though kim went ahead
and purchased 375 000 euros worth of
shares and announced that he was going
to help the company raise 50 million
euros once this news came out let's buy
it stock exploded and kim made 1.5
million euros on his initial investment
at which point he sold his stake and as
you would guess the 50 million euro
investment never came
this was clearly a pump and dump and the
prosecutors were once again on the hunt
for kim but this time it wasn't just the
prosecutors that were after kim either
after seeing his dubious investment
strategy the hacking community also
turned on kim in an effort to save faze
kim claimed that he had hacked into
osama suit in his bank account and he
put a 10 million bounty on osama's
location kim also launched a group
called the young intelligent hackers
against terrorism or yihat but this
publicity stun didn't work one hacker
named fluffy bunny actually hacked into
yihad's website and defaced the website
and with that kim knew that he was in
trouble and fled to thailand
unfortunately for kim thailand ended up
arresting him and deporting him back to
germany kim pleaded guilty to the
charges and somehow he was released with
a slap on the wrist once again he was
sentenced to just 20 months probation
and a 100 000 euro fine
again you would think that kim would
just lie low and play it safe but
instead he decided to start a hedge fund
in december of 2002 kim moved to hong
kong and founded a new business called
the empire limited the company's first
subsidiary was called a trend dax which
promised to leverage artificial
intelligence to generate 25 percent
annual returns given kim's past though
he was not actually allowed to take an
investment or trade nonetheless kim
tried to lure in investors using the
crazy returns but this didn't lead him
anywhere so kim tried launching more
businesses including data protect
limited investor limited and monkey
limited none of these really caught
steam though until he dived into the
file sharing business
by the time kim launched the file
sharing business though he was well
aware that his reputation was toast so
he decided to start from scratch and
rebuild a new reputation he started off
by legally changing his name from kim
schmidt to kim.com he also used holding
companies to distance himself from the
final product and he changed the name of
data protect limited to mega upload mega
upload was quite early for its time and
given that it was launched in 2005 so
kim had a pretty good shot at building a
reputable file sharing system but
knowing kim i don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that a large portion
of his customers were using the service
to share movies music and crack software
mega upload offered faster download
speeds for a fee and many users happily
paid the price this was extremely
lucrative for camera and he was finally
making the type of money that he had
been claiming to make for years kim
followed up mega upload with a dozen
services including mega video mega pigs
mega live mega pay and so on and so
forth in the meantime the fbi thought
that the entire thing was a mega fraud
and started hunting down kim once again
kim however was no longer in hong kong
he had since moved to new zealand and
acquired permanent residency but wait a
minute how did a person with a criminal
conviction secure residency so quickly
well kim basically bought his way in he
invested 24 million into a mansion in
auckland and he put 10 million dollars
in government bonds these investments
made kim an investor plus in new zealand
which granted him residency the fbi
wasn't going to let this move stop them
though every second that they wasted it
was millions of dollars in losses for
copyright holders
at the peak of mega upload the site
boasted 175 million revenue 50 million
daily visitors and accounted for four
percent of all internet traffic they
took the fbi some time but on january 5
2012 three indictments were filed
against kim which included racketeering
conspiracy to commit copyright
infringement and the conspiracy to
commit money laundering and just two
weeks later the new zealand police
raided his house with 76 officers and
two helicopters you might think that
this was a bit overkill and that's
because it was new zealand literally
sent their anti-terrorism special
tactics group to his mansion they ended
up seizing 18 luxury cars several large
tvs and 175 million dollars in cash
shortly after they also froze the 64
bank account and his numerous paypal
accounts and to top it all off they
threw km in mount eden prison and shut
down mega upload it seemed like this is
where kim's story would come to an end
but really the fbi hadn't accomplished
anything all they had done was poke the
bear
over the next few years kim's lawyers
and prosecutors fought back and forth
about extradition jail time and fines
you would think that this was an easy
case for prosecutors but that really
wasn't the case you see prosecutors had
to pull a lot of strings to arrest him
first of all the search warrant was
extremely broad and new zealand's court
of appeals ruled that the fbi's taking
up information was illegal secondly the
new zealand police had been spying on
kim for weeks before they raided the
house and in new zealand it is illegal
to spy on permanent residents and
citizens and finally they had used
excessive force when raiding his house
as they literally sent an anti-terrorist
squad against him kim was able to use
all these infractions plus a few others
to come to a confidential settlement
with the police in november of 2017. so
the fbi wasn't really able to do
anything about kim but at least they
shut down mega upload right well they
did indeed shut down mega upload but kim
went ahead and launched a new file
sharing and cloud storage website called
mega.nz exactly one year after the raid
on january 19 2013 him doesn't want any
more trouble with the authorities though
so he's made it clear that mega is not
for piracy kim wants everyone to know
that he is not a piracy king and he does
not support piracy by any means mega is
designed to be a competitor to google
drive and its high level of encryption
is simply designed to protect sensitive
personal data that's it similarly the
insanely fast upload and download speeds
are just perks for users it's not for
downloading massive games and software
in fact if you're a copyright owner and
find any of your content on mega you can
contact mega and kim is more than happy
to take down the content if we're being
real though mega is just a relaunch of
mega upload but this time it came as
being careful to stay on the legal side
of things as much as possible and that's
how kim.com began the internet's most
wanted man have you guys ever used mega
and what are your thoughts on piracy
comment that down below
also drop a like if you don't support
piracy either just like him and of
course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and to consider subscribe and see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one